i can tell you that while you're talking
putin kids gering während hier sprechen
tötet sie ihn weiter sie haben natürlich
bereits erwähnt was später bessere auch
die selben symptome hatte der war ja
auch an der charity die fälle das sind
menschen sogar mehrfach vergiftet wurden
sie haben ja alle einer politkowskaja
bereits erwähnte ja auch einmal
vergiftet worden war
mit einem tee und dann war das nicht
erfolgreich und später wurde sie an
putins geburtstag 2006 erschossen
es gibt eine ganz ganz lange liste von
putins gegner die starben plötzliche
herz und fragte vergiftungen erschossen
stellen sie sich mal vor dass dieser
versuch das ohne die führung hätte
passieren können er ist natürlich ein
fake präsident dieser putin dass ein
diktator
also sprechen sie doch einfach nicht
über wahlen das ist total unter
kontrolle von putins partei
navalny hat die natürlich eine bande von
dieben und gangstern genannten hat ja
völlig recht damit und natürlich gut ins
freunde hassen alle navalny weil er die
korruption anprangert man sich überhaupt
vorstellen dass jemand angreift ohne
dass putin davon wusste und dass er das
abgesegnet hat putin schaut jetzt
natürlich nach belarus und der hat dass
die das russische volk aufsteht so wie
es im augenblick in belarus zu sehen ist
und jetzt ist natürlich einer wahl nicht
aus dem spiel und das war natürlich ein
ganz naheliegende schluss